hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the top six new
chess openings now my definition for new
it's gonna be openings that over the
last five years have exploded in
popularity prior to five years you just
didn't see them played or talked about
all that often but in the last five
years these are the videos that people
are watching these are the requests that
come in and the growth in the number of
games people are actually playing have
exploded so i thought it'd be good to go
through the top six new chess openings
coming in at number six is the leukemia
gambit starts out from the italian game
one of the more popular openings in all
chess e4 e5
and then f3 knight c6 bishop c4 and
after bishop c5 and pawn d3
black plays the leukemia game it with
pawn f5 and then chaos ensues typically
white's going to play knight g5 and
black responds pawn f4 i did a video on
this with liukinigamit every move is a
trap because literally every single move
in this
is going to be a landmine for white to
walk into it is an extremely fun opening
for black so if you haven't tried this
one out definitely check out the
leukemia gambit
coming in at number five is the ortho
schnapp gambit and this is my favorite
way to attack the french defense i
typically play pawn to e4 to start and
when i see e6 i just have this internal
feeling of do i really have to play
against the french defense but after i
found the orthonor stop gambit
i just have the sense of relief of okay
it's go time now if you want to play the
french defense i am going to attack you
it starts out with e4
and then c4 so if they play their normal
d5 you can exchange in the center of the
board now queen b3 being extremely
aggressive and then after they take
bishop to c4 so if you're like me
and you want to be pretty aggressive
against the french defense you don't
know how to blow things up in the center
and continue your aggression
definitely try out the ortho schnapp
gambit
coming in at number four is the hyper
accelerated dragon and really this could
just be the dragon variations in the
sicilian as a whole because i feel like
that entire
genre of variations has been extremely
popular over the last five years but
after e4
c5 the sicilian knight to f3 the most
popular that i've seen recently is the
hyper accelerated dragon and then as to
play pawn g6 on just the second move in
the sicilian defense preparing for
bishop g7 gives you flexibility for what
you're doing with your central pawns you
can obviously get your knight involved
to c6 at some point but just the
flexibility it gives you while still
being very aggressive from black side
with a sicilian has made this one the
more popular defenses for black recently
coming in at number three if you watch
my videos you know i had to do something
on the king's gambit and the most
popular variation i've seen recently is
the triple museo gambit because it's the
most aggressive if you're playing the
king's gambit you're already being
pretty aggressive with f4 and after they
take here the triple museo says we are
just going absolutely all in we're
sacrificing any amount of material we
can
for a really really strong attack so
knight to f3
pawn g5 say let's just develop material
bishop to c4 attacking the pawn on f7
which is extremely weak early in the
game since the king is the only piece
defending it pawn to g4 we don't really
care too much about the night on f3
we're gonna castle on the king side
after the pawn takes we're gonna
get that pawn back with our queen really
just to develop our queen don't really
care too much about the material that's
not our game plan and after queen to f6
we're going to play pawn e5 let's give
up more material after they take with
our queen let's give up even more
material sacrifice our bishop on f7 but
now their king is completely exposed
after pawn d4 because why not let's just
give up one extra pawn and material then
we play bishop e3
this opening proves the concept of it
doesn't matter how much material you
have in the game it matters how much
material you have involved in the attack
this is a great way to attack your
opponent their king is exposed they
don't have a lot of their material
involved into the game and so if you
really understand this one this pawn is
being pinned down from this queen and
this rook we're attacking their queen it
is very difficult for black to continue
and defend correctly so i definitely
recommend checking out the triple muzo
gamut if you haven't already in the
king's gambit
coming in at number two we have the
nakmansen gamut and this is one that
before this came out i didn't know much
about it and then i started to play it
myself i felt like the entire chess
community did as well and realized this
is an extremely fun gambit so hopefully
you have played it before if not i think
you're definitely going to want to try
that out but it's in the italian game so
e4 e5 knight f3 knight c6 bishop c4 and
then instead of bishop down to c5 they
play knights f6
but from here we play d4 if they take we
castle on the king's side and after they
take our pawn on e4
we're going to sacrifice our knight on
c3
now to play typically continues with
them just taking our knight because why
not looks very strange for white to just
give up
that knight in material but white's not
done yet because white's not going to
play bishop takes on f7 check
sacrificing the bishop on f7 and after
the king takes queen to d5 and things
get spicy from here you can start to see
some of the threats the bishop can
easily get involved into the game the
queen is already in the central part of
the board this knight can get involved
the rook on f1 can get involved
the king is just hanging out here
where does the king go it's going to be
a lot of fun for white
black if they're not familiar are going
to have a tough time figuring out how to
defend so nachman's in gamut has been so
much fun over the years
to watch people play and to do analysis
on this but that's why it makes our list
at number two
coming in at number one on our list is
the stafford gambit a fan favorite so
many videos have been made on the
stafford gambit it took an opening that
was thought to be pretty passive and
defensive and not really that exciting
in the pet drop defense with e45
knight f3
knight f6 here and then the knight takes
on e5 and then d6 and the knight comes
back here to f3
and all of a sudden the staffer game it
says what if we don't play d6
what if instead we play knight c6 and
then the fun begins the accepted line is
the most popular with the night taking
and then the pawn recapturing here so
black is down a pawn and material but
you can see they've completely opened up
for
all their bishops their queens to get
involved into the action and it is
so much fun to play eric rosen's done a
good job of having so many games you can
watch him play fantastic chess player
check his channel out if you don't
already if you really like the stafford
game but he just has so much material on
that but the staffer gambit
has to be number one in the last five
years the explosion of this opening
everyone seems to be interested in it
this seems like the best way to play the
petrov and make the opening fun so i'm
curious from everyone
what would make your list did you like
the top six is there anything that i did
include that you think should have been
in there of the top six what is your
favorite what's been your favorite top
opening over the last five years
let me know in the comments below
and if you wouldn't mind hitting that
like button that lets me know that you
enjoyed the video but thank you guys so
much for watching and i'll see you in
the next video
you